I'll link the co-founder and myself
we're together for four or five years
and we decided to break up there was one
thing that was kind of reminder of our
relationship just a mentioning of like
who's gonna take the bunny
it felt really hard we thought wouldn't
it be great if there was a place or you
could just store it and just stays there
and it's safe you know it's safe but
it's just not there to remind you every
day to put it simply Museum a broken
relationship is a collection of items
and stories that were donated by people
after their relationships fell apart
I would like to donate the target that
my axe shot with an ak-47 when we were
together at the shooting range in LA
what else do you do when you come from
Denmark to LA you know you go to the
shooting range we get objects from all
over the world you know we open packages
and like what's inside and often times
to really get surprised in a Zagreb
hospital I met a beautiful young and
ambitious social worker from the
Ministry of Defense la was born when she
helped me get certain materials which is
a war invalid I needed from a bologna
proteases the prothesis endured longer
than our love it was made of sturdier
material the reason why we did this
because when we had when we experienced
a problem of what to do with this
something we were sure it already exists
and we went to google it to find the
place we just found the advice to how to
destroy it there are really some that
that is so striking I mean parachute
from Finland it's pretty pretty powerful
one I met him on my first parachute jump
I was really scared but this handsome
man who was my tandem jumping structure
saved me we love to play in the sky and
you loved each other then he died in a
parachute accident that's always the
thing with the crowdsource things you
have no idea what you're gonna get when
I moved out across the country
I took the toaster that will show you
how are you going to toast anything now
love and breakup it's such an important
part of our lives but you don't know
anything about it just left on your own
to experience it and
you have great parents or great friends
they will help you out if not nothing
it's really like that famous sentence
that everybody's happy in the same way
and unhappy in the special way a mobile
phone from Zagreb Croatia it was 300
days too long
she gave me his mobile phone so I
couldn't call him anymore
it's a permanent Museum one of the most
visited in Croatia which is for me still
funny
that word friends and business partners
we just changed the relationship from
one to another and it can be done I mean
we're proof that it can be done we still
travel a lot with visiting exhibitions
all over the world
and it's it's really great when you see
how well people respond I mean that's
why we do it really